Speaker 1: Let's go next to Mark from San Antonio,
Texas. Mark from San Antonio,
Welcome to The David Pakman Show.
Mark, please unmute yourself and
then I'll be able to hear you.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, quick question. You know,
I know the the loan forgiveness thing is kind of
sketchy right now. It's up in the air. But really,
why do you think there's no appetite from Congress
to have any kind of legislation around, you
know, either capping the amount that tuition
can be raised a year because it's exploding or
even taxing, you know, these endowments? I mean,
Harvard alone, I think, grew their endowment
during COVID by $30 billion. All of this is,
you know, essentially PAC money. You know, the
CEO of the Harvard Management Company is the
highest paid person associated with the with
the school. I mean, why do you think there's
no appetite to go legislate that? I mean, I
can understand the private loan side of it,
you know, very much in a lot of bed with
with Congress. But, you know, you know,
universities, by and large, really can't donate
to any kind of, you know, political affiliation.
Speaker 1: So I don't want to be defeatist. And
I know when I give you the reasons why we aren't
seeing those things, people will write to me and
they'll say, David, if you don't believe it can be
done, then of course it won't happen. You're going
to, you know, take the wind out of the sails. I'm
going to tell you why it hasn't been done for now
and why it's a difficult thing to do, putting a
limit on how much tuition can be increased.
I don't see how you could possibly pass that.
Republicans would say you're telling institutions
how they need to, you know, price their product
or service, which of course, is done. There are
there are industries that are price regulated,
but the opposition to that would be absolutely
off the charts in order to tax the endowments
of these institutions. Essentially, what you're
talking about is a wealth tax. I mean, remember
that we already have different types of taxes
for different types of financial transactions,
and some have no tax. But to say we're simply
going to tax the holdings is a sort of wealth tax.
And I just don't see any way in hell that right
now you get something like that passed doesn't
mean that these are bad ideas or we shouldn't try.
I'm not saying activists shouldn't be calling for
these things, but to answer the question of why
hasn't it happened, it's because these would be
such difficult things to get consensus for from
the current House and Senate of the United States.
Speaker 5: All right. Well, thank you. Quick
drummer question. I'm a drummer myself.
You know, I know you're a big fan of Josh Freese,
but as far as a player, you know, who do you try
to emulate the most or stylistically sound like?
Speaker 1: I don't think I have any particular
drummer I'm trying to emulate. I mean, I think
I, you know, study so many different drummers
from so many different genres and time periods.
But I couldn't really say there's any, any one,
any one person. I mean, you know, it's sort
of like you're going to learn things from like
Carter Beaufort, from Dave MATTHEWS Band that
are unique to Carter, and they're going to be
completely different from the things that
you'll pick up from like a Steve Gadd or,
you know, from watching old Buddy Rich videos
or whatever the case may be. So I think it's a
sort of consume everything sort of approach.
Speaker 5: Yeah. I mean, I started off as a
punk rock drummer, took a break from it for
a while, and when I came back, it was like,
Oh, I can't play the fast anymore. And so
then I started kind of listening to some,
you know, like you've mentioned Steve
Gadd and composer and all those guys.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's interesting. So you after
more after a break. Like you think physically you
can no longer play as fast.
Speaker 5: Correct? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, how old were you when you took
a break? And how old were you when you restarted?
Speaker 5: Person.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. You just cut out. I heard 30%.
Speaker 4: Start.
Speaker 5: I started around
12 years old and I played up until I was 18, 19,
you know, sold my gear, went to college and then
put it back up, I want to say 27.
Speaker 1: Wow. And then you had a
diminished, diminished physical capacity.
Speaker 5: Right. Jeez. I mean,
foot speed was kind of gone. And I'm
sure if I committed to it and, you know,
really tried, I could get some of
those chops back. But also it was
just like a complete disinterest in it.
Speaker 1: Fair. Fair. All right. Well,
we're going to look into it strongly. Okay.
Thanks very much. Appreciate the call.